- À la COP 27, la conférence
des Nations unies sur le climat,
sur un des points principaux
de l'Accord de Paris de 2015 :
limiter l'augmentation moyenne
de la planète à 1,5°.
Considéré à l'époque
dans la lutte au réchauffement
climatique, cet objectif
pourrait bien être exclu
de la résolution finale.
L'ancien secrétaire d'État
de Barack Obama aimerait
bien qu'il en soit autre
En cecececece de presse,
John Kerry souligne que
l'Égypte, le pays hôte du sommet
d'être considéré comme le pays
du recul par rapport au dernie
sommet sur le climat à Glasgow,
en Écosse.
- L'Accord
pour le climat est accepté.
- En 2015, drererererere
de l'Accord de Paris,gogogogogoe
entier s'étaient entendus
pour tenter de limiter
l'augmentation moyenne
de la température mondiale
"Il en va de la santé
de la planète et des
générations futures",
selon cette ancien médecin
veK K K K K K K K K K K K K K Ke
Climat-Énergie Greenpeace Canada
- On voit que les négociations
s'intensifient. C'est normal
d'avoir ce genre d'essai de
diluer l'accord. Le 1,5° est là
pour reste là là là là là là et
on espère évidemment que
ça va aller beaucoup plus loin
- La COP 27 se termine
il y a encore lieu d'espérer que
les pays parviennent à u
incluant la cible de 1,5°.
Radio-Canada, Montréa